In February 2022,
the World Journal of Oncology
published an article by a team of 13
researchers claiming that vapers
are about as likely to get cancer as
people who smoked traditional
cigarets.
Citing this article, Stanton Glantz,
a tobacco control activist and
retired professor of medicine at the
University of California, San
Francisco, claimed that not only
are there some carcinogens in
e-cigarette aerosol, but
now there is also direct evidence
that people who use e-cigarettes are
at increased risk of some cancers.
And then the World Journal of
Oncology's editors retracted
this study because concerns have
been raised regarding the article's
methodology source data processing,
including statistical analysis
and reliability of conclusions.
The editors of the Journal in their
papers, peer reviewers failed to
notice the study's many flaws prior
to publication, but they ultimately
concluded that it was bad enough to
retract. Even so, it's worth
dwelling on the problems because
they are typical of what we see with
statistical studies on this topic
and other public policy issues.
The retracted study claimed a large
sample size with data on 154,856
subjects.
For assessing the cancer risk of
vaping versus traditional smoking,
what we should be looking at
our vapers who never smoked
traditional cigarets and yet have
cancer. There were 180 vapers
with cancer in the study, but based
on general population percentages,
probably fewer than 100 of them had
never smoked. Traditional cigarets.
That's too small a sample to draw
robust conclusions.
The median age of vapers in the
study was 25 versus
62 for the traditional smokers,
and they had very different
breakdowns of income, race, sex
and medical conditions.
Adjusting for all these factors
would require a minimum of a
thousand observations.
If researchers can query the same
data sets and arrive at completely
bizarre results that are as strong
or even stronger than the ones
they're reporting, they're doing
something wrong.
In this case, the authors claimed
active vapers had 2.2 times
the risk of cancer as the control
group, but their logistic regression
showed that people who never used
cocaine, heroin or methamphetamines
also had a 2.2 times higher
risk of getting cancer.
Why didn't the authors run with this
finding?
That cocaine might be a cancer
preventative?
Because it's absurd and would likely
have brought ridicule.
According to the researchers data,
being white raises
your cancer risk by 2.6 times.
Having a middle income of between
25,000 to 65,000
raises your risk 2.3 times.
The authors didn't report these
spectacular findings either.
This paper is among the worst of the
anti-vaping articles that managed to
get published in respectable peer
review journals and cited by
regulators and legislators.
But even the best studies haven't
surmounted a key statistical issue,
and they tend to distort the
evidence to make vaping look
dangerous.
An analysis in Internal in Emergency
Medicine noted 11 flawed studies
that linked vaping to various
diseases.
Some of these studies relied on
surveys that don't report when
respondents began vaping.
But the Population Assessment of
Tobacco and Health Study reports
age ranges for initiation of
smoking and vaping, as well as
diagnoses.
Based on that survey, the authors
of the Internal in Emergency
Medicine article found that subjects
diagnosed with cancer typically
started vaping after they were
diagnosed with their conditions.
In fact, just 4% of e-cigarette
users were definitely diagnosed
after they started vaping.
By contrast, about 98%
of smokers were diagnosed after they
started smoking.
Overall, 99% of
cases involve people with a history
of smoking and just 2.3%
of vapers diagnosed with one of the
four health conditions covered by
this study had never been cigaret
smokers.
The tiny population of vapers who
never smoked traditional cigarets
and who started using e-cigarettes
before being diagnosed with a health
condition is hard to identify,
unrepresentative of the general
population and likely too small
to draw conclusions from.
No amount of tricky statistical work
can overcome this basic data issue.
There's another problem with the way
the results of these studies are
reported.
Even if it does turn out that vaping
has negative health consequences, it
may still be a net positive for
users who otherwise would go back to
traditional cigarets.
And banning e-cigarettes altogether
would cause some people to turn to
the black market to get their vaping
fix.
Then they would have no idea what
they're sucking into their lungs
because there would be no quality
control.
In 2019, underground
manufacturers of marijuana vapes
mixed vitamin E acetate into
their products, which likely
explains why 2,807
people ended up hospitalized and
68 died. Proving that traditional
cigarets cause cancer, which they
do, required two types of
data; Observational studies
and experimental studies.
First people noticed that cancer
patients were more likely to be
smokers and non cancer patients,
and then careful experimentation
teased out some of the mechanisms by
which smoking led to cancer.
Observational studies, even without
data issues, can show only an
association not causation,
although most vaping studies claim
only an association, journailsts,
activists and public officials are
quick to assert causation.
Experimental studies can show
causation, but can't measure the
practical extent of an issue or
possible offsetting factors.
One experimental study on vaping
that drew press attention was
published in the Journal of Nuclear
Medicine under the title "Molecular
Imaging of Pulmonary Inflammation
and Electronic and Combustible
Cigaret Users: a Pilot Study."
A new study shows e-cigarettes cause
more inflammation in the lungs than
traditional cigarets.
The researchers at the University of
Pennsylvania say vape devices
cause unique damage to the
lungs that is not yet fully
understood.
One problem with this particular
paper is that it studied only 15
people.
Five vapers, five users of
traditional cigarets and five
people who didn't smoke at all.
However carefully you select groups
of five subjects that can't
represent a broad enough
cross-section of users to draw any
solid conclusions that would require
hundreds of participants.
This experiment also relied on
screening volunteers and made no
attempt at randomness or sampling
the range of population, meaning
that each of the three groups of
five subjects differed from each
other in important ways.
The paper did not show that vaping
causes increased lung damage.
In fact, the research didn't check
for that.
Instead, it looked for biomarkers
or chemicals thought to be
associated with lung damage.
By that measure, they found no
difference between the five vapers
and the control group of five people
who had never vaped or smoked.
The study did find that uptake of a
chemical thought to react to a
biomarker for lung damage was higher
in the five vapers than in the
control group.
But the five cigaret smokers
included in the study had a lower
uptake of that chemical than the
controls, which makes a conclusion
suspect, since we know traditional
cigarets cause lung damage.
Most likely the correlation can be
attributed to random chance.
And this was a pilot study, meaning
it was aimed not at generating firm
conclusions but in testing
procedures and determining which
hypotheses could be tested
in a subsequent study.
The authors mention more than 30
statistical tests at the 5% level
of significance, and they may have
conducted more. The 5% significance
level means there's a 5% chance
of getting a positive result by
random chance, even if there is no
association at all in your data.
With 30 tests, you expect 1.5
positive results.
Even if vaping is unrelated to lung
health. The authors got two positive
results out of 30, which is hardly
strong evidence of anything, and the
two results are among the least
direct in terms of linking vaping to
lung damage.
The more direct tests of biomarkers
failed to find any differences among
the groups.
A classic prohibitionist argument is
that while a controversial activity
may not be harmful in itself, it
leads to bad things.
In the case of vaping, several
studies suggest that young vapers
are something like seven times as
likely to smoke traditional cigarets
in the future than similar young
people who don't vape.
The data is pretty clear.
So far in the limited studies we
have that it looks like it is a
gateway for youth smoking.
An oft cited paper in this area
"E-cigarettes and Future
Cigaret Use" is typical of the
genre.
And of 298 Southern California's
17 year old high school students who
didn't vape only 11% were
smoking cigarets a year later.
Among those who were vaping at 17,
40% had taken up old fashioned
cigarets at 18.
The paper did a lot of additional
analysis, but this is the basic
statistic driving the conclusion.
To the authors credit, they were
careful to label this an association
between vaping and future smoking
rather than claiming that vaping
caused future smoking.
Yet when this paper was cited by
regulatory authorities, they
interpreted it as causal evidence
and therefore as a justification to
restrict vaping.
There are reasons to be skeptical
about this kind of research.
Not everyone is honest when they
fill out a survey, especially young
people asked about activities that
are frowned upon, and only 14%
of the students interviewed at age
17 participated in the follow
up survey a year later.
The missing students may be
systematically different from the
ones recorded in the study.
It's also plausible that teenagers
who vape differ from teenagers who
don't in ways that independently
affect their likelihood of smoking.
Perhaps the type of kid who vapes at
17 is more likely to smoke at
18.
In that case, restricting vaping
among 17 year-olds probably won't
reduce smoking at age 18.
In fact, some 17 year-old vapers
will switch to traditional cigarets
or turn to underground purveyors of
e-cigarettes, which would pose a
much more serious health risk.
There's plenty of evidence that many
smokers use vaping to reduce or quit
smoking. In fact, adolescent smoking
has continued to fall as adolescent
vaping has increased.
Another anti-vaping argument is that
it has negative mental or social
health consequences.
Studies like "Electronic Cigaret
Use and Mental Health," the Canadian
population based study, suffer
from the same issues as studies
linking vaping to future smoking.
It's easy to show that vapers have
more psychological and social issues
than non-vapers, but that's only an
association.
And obvious alternative explanation
is that troubled kids are more
likely to vape either as a form
of self-medication or because they
have less regard for adult opinion
and rules are perhaps because they
are less supervised or have less to
lose by acting in a diviant way.
Even if we did have good
observational studies suggesting
that vaping is reliably associated
with future smoking, or that vaping
is associated with mental and health
problems, we would still need
experimental studies to support
causal claims.
Most real experiments are unethical
since participants would have to be
randomly assigned to either vape or
avoid vaping, which is why
researchers look for natural
experiments.
A good example of a natural
experiment is intended and
unintended effects of e-cigarette
taxes on youth tobacco use.
The authors used data on youth
smoking and vaping rates in ten
states and two large counties that
enacted e-cigarette taxes between
2010 and 2019.
They found that taxes were
associated with a reduction in
vaping among young people, but they
were also associated with an
increase in young people smoking
traditional cigarets.
That's good evidence that vaping and
smoking are substitutes. If vaping
led to smoking, a decrease in vaping
would lead to a decrease in smoking.
Several other natural experiment
studies reinforce the idea that
vaping and smoking are substitutes,
although the rate of substitution
seems to vary in different
populations.
But we still have a lot to learn in
this area. The evidence to date
suggests that discouraging vaping
will lead to increased smoking and
very likely worse public health.
This research suggests that the 15
to 20% e-cigarette tax,
which was part of the original Build
Back better act that was eventually
taken out, probably would have
reduced youth vaping by about 3%
and increase youth smoking by about
2%.
Given the evidence that vaping is
far less hazardous than smoking,
more teen-smoking instead of vaping
doesn't represent an improvement in
public health.
None of this research shows that
vaping is safe and it doesn't rule
out the possibility of negative
health effects that haven't been
found yet. But in public policy,
the most important question is
instead of what?
In real life there are no solutions,
only trade offs.
There's overwhelming evidence that
the alternative to vaping is cigaret
smoking. Vaping represents a huge
improvement for public health.
Government officials generally fail
to reason in these terms.
They tax, ban, and regulate
as if their policies exist in a
vacuum, setting statistically
dubious studies to support their
preconceived policies.